you guys want to play the name game oh
my boy
hit it this would be good jelly roll
aha guess who's back
what's up bubba's i figured we'd do a
thing today called the name
game in honor of president's day i want
you both to list the name of every
president
you can name or think of can't wait to
hear this one
[Laughter]
man and uh so this time we're actually
going to put a timer on it chin's got
it should we do 10 seconds we're uh you
three are going around the room theo
brandon and joe trying to name it okay
so what do we do what one one president
each or we just saw just one president
uh yeah yeah once you go i'll go theo
goes okay so we start now go ahead
abraham lincoln george washington easy
one easy one
um i'm gonna go with grover cleveland
hard one
wow yeah he definitely looked this up
before jfk
he didn't have it stop ten seconds
no no no ten seconds for each person oh
so just like once once
someone hits it so keep going how would
you ever think that it's ten seconds for
the whole game
the worst game ever
how would you ever think it's ten
seconds for the whole game
time time nope that's it they only got
three jet is great
like
[Music]
george washington all right no i'm sorry
you [ __ ] get lost
bush oh no i want to keep going
bush george bush yeah i was gonna say
george bush what but you didn't
i got 10 seconds though but
he's gonna say something say say that i
got bush go theo
all right dude i'll say donald trump oh
that's a good one
uh i'm gonna say uh obama
nice i'll go with biden nice
i'll go with um gerald ford got
it carter nixon
nice all the reindeer
fade on reindeer games sorry that was a
joke
um i will go with uh your boy
uh 10 seconds would you say
stephen douglas it's steve
steven douglas did you just say one of
the douglasses from
and michael with his younger brother
stephen hey is stephen douglas a
president
douglas i'm gonna go i'm gonna go with
uh
charlie sheen stephen he was a president
he was stephen a douglas was a
senator he was a president nick
of the united states are you i think so
we'll keep reading his wiki i i am
yeah just senator top billing senator
stephen a douglas he looks presidential
deal lost or me and i don't know keep
going or do we just
count yeah cheaters yeah you guys could
keep going if
you creeps uh clinton uh biden
nope you already said that joe you're
winner
i'd like to get uh dude hoodie if i
could
yeah we'll say something we're going to
send you a
a stephen douglas presidential shirt
bro he is president of the south that is
true oh
nice which still doesn't work yeah
that's fine
pick someone from the confederacy yeah
it was weird man
look my confederacy is confederacy of
dunces that's my favorite one to support
and that's written by robert after
stephen jackson was gonna say colonel
mustard
[Laughter]
uh you guys left uh george w bush on the
table that was an easy one but that's
pretty much all i could have gotten yeah
after that whenever they
whenever the pictures start turning
black and white that's when it gets a
little dicey
yeah yeah all right that was a fun one
though thanks jelly roll
thanks jelly roll
[Music]